alors que le maire de mantes-la-jolie a
démissionné la date du scrutin se fait
attendre tour d'horizon des candidats à
la municipale partielle actuellement
adjoint au maire à l'urbanisme jean luc
santini est soutenu par le président du
département des yvelines pierre bédier
il peut également compter sur 31 élus
municipaux
de son côté raphaël cogner a quant à lui
décidé de repartir à la reconquête de sa
ville il peut compter sur certains de
ses anciens adjoints il y aura
effectivement un certain nombre
d'anciens élus qui sont restés avec moi
qu'à ceux qui sont déjà là même boire il
ya ceux qui attend que la campagne soit
vraiment lancée dans les deux camps les
projets pour la ville sont quasi
similaires si aujourd'hui on fait une
mesure un petit peu d'urgence pour
l'hiver pour les sdf ça sera dans
l'avenir une mesure beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus précise et puis il ya les
deux grands thèmes qui sont l'anru pour
le val fourré et le coeur de ville pour
le pour le centre ville on peut
raisonner par cartier dans le quartier
du val fourré ya évidemment le plan revu
que j'ai lancée puisque l'anru était en
campagne depuis une dizaine d'années
donc le renouvellement du quartier du
val fourré ça c'est un dossier très
important en centre-ville on a le
d'oxydation coeur de ville avec tout le
soutien au commerce et le travail qu'on
fait sur les espaces publics et la mise
en valeur de la nature et de la haie de
notre centre-ville qui est un centre
ville magnifique et puis dans le
quartier de gassicourt il ya tout ce que
j'ai déjà fait autour du fait de rendre
la nature plus présents dans la ville
enfin guillaume quévarec ancien élu
municipal de la ville va mener une liste
de gauche rassemblée france insoumise
europe ecologie les verts et socialistes
inédit à mantes-la-jolie on est on est
motivés parce qu'effectivement ce qui se
passe sur la ville de mantes-la-jolie
depuis plusieurs mois et d'assez
destructeur les déplorables et on a
vraiment envie proposer autre chose pour
nous vraiment bédié cogner c'est le
passé bédié cogner c'est dépassé et nous
vraiment on va proposer quelque chose de
positif et nous on prend représente
l'avenir pour mantes la jolie guillaume
quévarec peut compter sur audrey alliés
membres de la france insoumise jean-paul
carcelès secrétaire de section parti
socialiste à mantes la jolie ou encore
stéphane barnier responsable europe
ecologie les verts à mantes la jolie on
a un axe fort qui pour nous important
pour la ville de mantes la jolie c'est
effectivement tous qu'ils aient
l'honnêteté et lutte contre la
corruption après on a des enjeux je les
dis sur la démocratie citoyenne et
participative pour faire en sorte que
les habitants de notre ville s'implique
dans la ville et dans les projets et
puis on a une ville qui est fracturé une
ville avec de grandes difficultés
sociales donc des actions autour de la
solidarité et puis la réussite éducative
des son côté marc jamais membre du parti
communiste français vient de l'annoncer
il conduira une liste seule lors de la
prochaines municipales partielles